[Captions by Judy V. at Y Translator]
Liquid nitrogen gets amazingly cold.
And hundreds of you,
and we wanted to know,
what would happen if we put
cotton candy into liquid nitrogen.
And when we tried it out,
the result was very surprising.
[Music]
To show what we expect to happen when
we dip something into liquid nitrogen,
let's take a few flowers and leaves,
freeze them in the liquid nitrogen,
and smack them on this
brick and watch what happens.
[Music]
Exploded.
Let's try it with one of this flower.
I don't know what this flower is
called, but we're going to freeze it,
and then see if it shatters.
[Music]
Shattered.
Now we've got a little leaf.
Let's try it with the leaf.
[Music]
Breaks as if it were
an old dry leaf in the fall.
Turns to powder basically.
And then as it warms up,
it just goes back to being flexible.
We know how flowers and leaves
react when we put it into liquid nitrogen.
And so I expected something
similar to happen with cotton candy.
It's very thin and I thought
that perhaps as it froze,
it would become
less flexible and more brittle,
but that's not what happened.
Here's the basic idea.
We'll take some cotton candy, quickly
drop it down into the liquid nitrogen,
pull it out, and smash it down in this brick,
and see if it shatters or
if something else happens.
We'll follow that up by
seeing if we get the same result
if we leave the cotton candy in liquid
nitrogen for a longer period of time.
[Music]
The cotton candy dipped in liquid nitrogen,
acts almost exactly like a
normal cotton ball dipped in water.
Normally, you can't have wet cotton candy.
You put it into water and
it just dissolves immediately.
But the sugar that cotton candy is made
of doesn't dissolve in liquid nitrogen.
As a result, the cotton candy
soaks up the liquid nitrogen,
just like a normal cotton
ball soaking up water.
Look at that.
It's dripping out from cotton candy.
Cotton candy is dry,
or it's dissolved normally,
so this was really
surprising when we tried it out.
Look at this.
You can even squeeze the
liquid nitrogen right out of it.
[Music]
Soaking it up like a sponge.
It's now saturated with liquid nitrogen.
[Music]
Ah, some of it splashed onto my neck.
I know what cotton candy is like
normally if I eat it.
I'm a little bit nervous about trying to eat
it when it's been dipped in liquid nitrogen,
because as you've just seen,
it acts like a sponge almost.
I think if I have the cotton candy dipped
in liquid nitrogen,
and then put in my mouth,
it would just burn my mouth.
All of that liquid nitrogen
would freeze inside of my mouth shut.
So I'm going to dip it in, and then
try breaking off just a little piece of it.
See how that goes.
Here we go.
I missed. Don't show that, or do.
Whoa.
That is very cold.
I was keeping it rolling around
with my tongue the whole time,
and I think I still freezer
burned my tongue a little bit.
Three. Two. One.
[Music]
Water.
Liquid nitrogen.
It's clearly boiling the liquid nitrogen,
because everything
makes liquid nitrogen boil.
But when you put it into the
water, it just dissipates immediately.
You can keep putting it in too.
It just doesn't stop dissolving.
It's dipped in the liquid nitrogen,
completely intact.
And let's take the stuff in
the liquid nitrogen,
and now put it into the cup of water,
and see what happens.
[Music]
That is odd.
I think it's dissolved.
So we expected our cotton candy
to just freeze in the liquid nitrogen,
and then kind of shatter,
the way it did with flowers.
Flowers and plant life of course
are full of water on the inside,
and that can freeze very solid
causing things to be extra brittle.
But I did think that cotton candy
would be a little bit more like a plant,
and a little bit less like a cotton ball.
Guys, there's more for you to see.
That little box up at the top
will transport you
to our last video in case you missed it.
You should go check it out.
The box at the bottom will show you what
YouTube thinks you should be watching next.
And this bomb here in the
center will subscribe to our channel,
so you never miss another video.
Don't forget to ring that bell.
And we'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.